hi there today we're looking at
evaluating NLP models via contrast sets
and these are too many authors from too
many places for me to read out so we'll
just jump right into the problem so what
is the problem or let's jump into the
solution here you see a visual question
answering tasks visual question
answering in this case you have two
pictures right here picture one picture
two and a sentence two similarly colored
and similarly post ciao dogs are face to
face in one image right and I guess the
task here is to see to have the system
answer is this correct or incorrect and
as you see here I believe that's a
correct statement or your your maybe
task to ask which is the image that this
applies to right is it image one or
image 2 and of course here it's image
one now the the problem with such
systems is that there are a lot of easy
things that the models can do that will
usually get them the answer what we like
to imagine is that the model will look
at this and recognize that this is a dog
here right this is a dog here is its
face and this is a dog and here is its
face and it will see aha there's a count
there's a two of them right there's two
of them and there's the notion of face
and there's notion of pose and so on but
usually there are tricks that the models
can do to get this easier for example I
know that in a particular visual
question answering system whenever there
is a question of what is the ground
covered in
or something like this the answer is
always snow right you don't even have to
look at the image and similarly there
are a lot of these kind of tricks that
the models learn and the author's
recognize correctly that this is mostly
a data set problem right so the data set
usually what you do in these data sets
is you have an image right kevn you have
an image that you scrape from the web or
something and it has some mountains and
maybe right and then there's there's
there's snow right on the mountains on
the ground and maybe a house and you
give this to a bunch of to a Mechanical
Turk or someone like a Raider and you
instruct them you produce a question to
this image you give them a couple of
examples right and they're usually kinda
lazy and they will just look at it and
be like what questions can I ask okay
I'll I'll ask you know you need to ask
something usually the instructions are
it must be visual and it must maybe be
answerable with a one-word answer or
something like this right or it must you
know it must be a multiple choice
question so there are these number of
instructions there will usually be like
oh okay what's kind of special about
this picture
okay there's snows I'm going to ask
about that snow right so the the problem
is mainly the process of data set
generation right that is that will lead
to kind of biases and easy solutions for
the models where the models they will
simply kind of learn statistical
correlations between things and the
intention so we have a big diver anti
divergence between the intention of what
the data set creators want right the
intention is in this case is visual
understanding
visual of the world and there's a big
big difference between this and between
how the data set is really constructed
so the authors are trying to address
this with what they call contrast sets
now they say okay you get out of this
process here you get a data set right
you get a training data set and a test
data set maybe here a smaller test data
set what they say is what we should do
is we should additionally have these
things called contrast sets right so
this is train this is test and usually
these two come from the same
distribution right you simply make them
and then you split them somehow
and you take the test from the train but
these here are not from the same
distribution this is the contrast what
they argue is that the authors of the
data set should create the contrast set
right so you see that there's a split
here where the data set comes from they
argued at the authors of the data set
with knowing what intention they have
they should create the contrast data set
manually by hand in order to make kind
of really hard examples that show what
they want out of a system they capture
this here in their example so if we go
back to the example here are things and
they suggest to do this via
perturbations so what they would do is
they would start at this example up here
right I would start and they would
perturb it textually or via image so
they would perturb it to make it change
the label the gold label this is
different from adversarial examples in
adversarial examples you want to perturb
a sample such that it is still the same
but to
classifier it's different here we have
the opposite goal you want to make
something that is means kind of the
opposite but you want to test whether
your classifier can pick up on that so
in this case the one example would be to
similarly color and similarly post cats
instead of dogs right or face-to-face in
one image that would change the label
right the if whereas before the answer
was yes that's a correct sentence now
it's no that's not a correct sentence
there are no cats in these images also
if three similarly colored dogs so the
intention of the author's you have to
view it through this lens the intention
here is that the system can recognize
the species right of the entities in
their images the system can count and
the system can compare right compare in
this case colors so you want to kind of
make perturbations on these attributes
from a test image right you can also
think about image perturbations where
you keep the sentence but you modify the
image such that there are still two dogs
and they're similar still facing each
other but and but they're not similarly
colored anymore right
so they similarly colored here would be
the the attribute that were before it
was true now it's false with the new
image right so you get the gist that the
people that created the data set that no
their intention will create manually
these samples and the authors they
proposed a new metric to track this but
essentially the authors proposed how
well models do when this contrast sets
will be a reflection it should be it
should be kind of an additional thing
that people do with their NLP models all
right so you get the picture
i that is i believe the the entire arm
gist of this paper
and I have some problems first of all
here they say all right let's give a toy
example in two dimensions say you have
this data set right and the red one is
the correct decision boundary right and
you want to capture that but because you
only have limited training data and
because you in in this generation
processes you have a systematic biases
so if we had non systematic biases we
would think that okay we maybe pick this
and this one and this one here and this
one here and this one here right we
don't get all of them but we kind of get
an ID sample right that wouldn't be so
much of a problem you could still kind
of recover the decision boundary but
because we have systematic biases the
authors argue we we actually introduced
biases so the systematic bias here is
that we would of the blue ones we would
only capture things on this sorry on the
on this layer up here and of the red
ones orange won't be the only capture
things of the level down here and
thereby we introduced the kind of data
set the bias
it doesn't require this complex decision
boundary anymore right and if we now
that the problem is if we collect the
data set like this and we simply say
well these ones are the test set and
these ones are the trained said right
it will generalize well to the test set
but it will not generalize well to what
we actually want and therefore the
authors say well if we introduces
contrast sets here then you see that the
decision boundary that we found will not
perform well on these contrast sets
right so they would say we take one
example of the test set like this is you
can see this is this example right here
and we would perturb it to make it
change its label or in this case one of
them where the label remains we would
kind of perturb it meaningfully and yeah
so as I said I have multiple problems
with this first 2d toy examples very
very bad for NLP models
first of all low dimensional intuition
does not generalize to high dimensional
intuition like very very little second
of all even worse usually these NLP
modes have so many parameters much more
parameters then you have data set that
which means that your decision boundary
is instantly going to be simple even if
you had all the data you can possibly
want this it it's just a very different
kind of problem and then the next
problem is if even with by doing this
contrast and you already see it here
right you already see it you can only
kind of bicker about the data okay but
with the contrast that you only really
capture this one aspect so if that was
actually well adhere to you could
measure very locally whether or not this
this would work or not and the ability
to come up with meaningful contrast sets
to ever capture what the model is doing
is almost impossible because you have to
create them manually and then you
suggest that the authors themselves make
these contrast sets remember the authors
are the ones that gave these
instructions right these instructions
right here
the authors provided them to the to the
data set annotators so the authors will
probably be even more biased if they
have to do their own right if they have
to now create their own contrast
examples they will probably even though
they know their intention they will
probably be like more biased than if you
at least this year at least this year is
a distributed process across people
right so you get things that you
wouldn't have thought of but if just the
three authors of the date of the paper
make the contrast examples I would argue
that's that's an even more advised
measure often so all of this it just
strikes me as as the papers basically
saying let's try on a few things and I
think the fundamental problem is much
much deeper and it goes with this
intention part like I get it the the
visual question answering dataset
doesn't capture the doesn't capture what
you want it it doesn't make the model
suddenly understand that there are dogs
and there are species of animal and so
on it simply makes it correlate things
but that's what deep learning and
especially NLP does so right it is like
it's like saying you you build a build
an image net classifier and it can't fly
and and identify if I try it on my test
that it requires my computer to fly and
my image net model can do this then it
doesn't serve my intention right I mean
it's it's a crass example but ultimately
you the correct approach should be to
better encapsulate your intention into
the data set generating process and then
correctly interpreting the results that
mean okay on this data set as far as we
can tell the way we created it this is
the performance of the model it doesn't
the model will never learn to fulfill
your intention and I get it that's what
you're saying but still even with these
contrasts said I think it's a really bad
measure to formally propose its I think
you should much more propose how is the
data set generating process different
from what you want and what are the
limitations there right and so that's
that that I think that will lead to much
more meaningful meaningful results than
simply the author's providing a few
manually put examples that they feel
capture their attention it will not know
the reason we do deep learning instead
of straightforward if-else programming
is begin because we cannot capture even
our intentions and therefore dataset
generation is the only is the only
method we have so the same all right
so ultimately I believe these this whole
NLP especially the visual question
answering and so on the natural language
understanding part needs to have a
grounding so ultimately I think
grounding grounded NLP it means
basically that you're not only doing an
LP which is simply you take text and you
take images and you correlate them
somehow
right you just make a statistical
connection grounded NLP models is the
hope that you could build something that
actually understands the world
understands that there's entities that
he's interacted there's something like a
pose that there is um something like
what the color means right what a dog is
and so on and as entities I think we're
not there yet and I think that will be
the ultimate solution to these kind of
tasks not not any sort of local very
local very low dimensional perturbation
I mean yeah let's say you create a
contrast set you will be able to capture
one tiny little bit of your intention
one tiny little bit even though you know
your intention you will capture a tiny
little bit all of the thousand other
degrees of freedom of your own intention
you won't be able in there to capture in
the contrast set I guarantee you all
right that was my course with that I
invite you to read the whole paper they
actually do this for NLP datasets it's a
lot of work and they show
that the models perform much worse on
their contrast sets and interestingly
the human stones the humans are able to
solve the contras of course of course
because you tell the humans what the
task is right that's like humans succeed
on contrast at like how surprising what
you should do is you should just provide
the humans with the dataset not tell
them what the task is even worse just
provide them with the encoded data set
like not the text itself but actually
the token IDs right and then and then
make them do the thing and the humans
will just as well make a statistical
correlation between the tokens and the
images or whatnot and the humans will
fail just as well on the test on these
contrasts that's because the humans
maybe they'll figure out what the task
is but probably not so humans succeed
and contrast said how surprising you
tell them the intention while you don't
tell it to the model yes I see critical
but yeah please read the paper and it's
an interesting paper and with that